today on stick to football we are gonna
get you caught up on everything that
happened over the weekend we were in
Austin Texas so we didn't get a chance
to talk about the a be signing after it
happened we didn't get to talk to you
about the Texas LSU game which is good
because I was in a terrible mood but
Connor we get to go really around the
league and around the colleges basically
to get everyone caught up from a draft
standpoint from a college football
standpoint from an NFL standpoint just a
reminder you can watch the show on
youtube if you want to listen to us we
love for you to do that
Apple podcast Spotify wherever you get
your shows but if you miss these faces
Bleacher Report's youtube channel you
can watch the show two to three times a
week depending on when we're on the road
basically yeah and one more update we
always listen to your guys feedback
whether it's iTunes reviews Twitter
Instagram DMS and we have heard your
complaints about our ad blocks being
longer recently and we've actually been
able to reduce those so those will be
much shorter going forward if it wasn't
bothered you we totally understand it
takes a while to get segment from
segment when we have two to three ads so
those will be tighter and more condensed
so stick with us here that's really
exciting we had a great weekend in
Austin obviously touring the facility
seeing the game hanging out with the
awesome listeners but of course there
always has to be a caveat for all great
weekend's Antonio Brown signs with the
New England Patriots and this is
something we talked about on the
tailgate show the potential of it
we felt like it's something that had a
chance of happening we were just
wondering if the money would come on the
table Matt where do we even start with
this yeah I think we start number one I
had a lot of folks say like hey guys you
didn't talk about a B and he's like this
is the the great thing about a podcast
and then the awful thing about a podcast
once you recorded it's kind of in the
book it's done how do you it's over
we'll talk about it next show I'm not
surprised I was even telling you guys
while we were just sitting around I
thought there were three possibilities
New England the Washington Redskins or
he would just retire and never play
football again you know he wouldn't say
what for whatever reason but that's also
like we didn't have the full picture the
full picture in my and I'm gonna go full
conspiracy theory I firmly believe the a
B got to Oakland realized that was not
where he wanted to be
executed and orchestrated his way out of
Oakland whether that's you know skipping
camp the feet thing the helmet thing
going at going at mike Mayock releasing
pictures an audio of conversations and
it finds I believe that he got where he
ultimately wanted let's not forget when
the Steelers said they were gonna trade
a be the team that had the most interest
was the New England Patriots and the
Steelers said no we are not gonna let
you go to our rival we are not gonna let
you go to the best team in the world who
just won a Super Bowl it ain't happenin
well guess what it did this reminds me
so much of when Brett Favre wanted to be
a Minnesota Viking and the Packers were
like no he's like okay well I'll go be a
jet just release me just release my
rights I've retired released my rights
I'll go be in New York jet he does that
for like what a year and then guess
where he ends up the Minnesota Vikings
this is what a B did just perfectly
schemed this is Game of Thrones [ __ ] man
he schemed his way out of Oakland and
now he's a patriot there is no worse
scenario for the rest of the NFL than an
Antonio Brown being a member of the New
England Patriots where by the way he
will be a boy scout guaranteed I
remember when Favre was traded to the
Jets minute Green Bay was so nervous
about him going to Minnesota they put a
clause in the deal that the Jets could
not move him to Minnesota and when you
look at this players that are great
players always find a way to get what
they want and a B I mean like you said
Matt whether it was the feet whether it
was the altercations the social media
antics and videos there was always
something and eventually he got exactly
what he wanted you saw the celebration
as he's looking at his phone reading
that he's been released it's just
unbelievable I do agree with you that I
think everything will be fine in New
England now I will say he is someone
that has been you know he cares a lot
about his targets more than anyone now
maybe that won't be the case in New
England because when you go to New
England there's a lot of mouths to feed
and Josh Gordon Julian Edelman all those
running backs they're pretty content no
matter the outcome as long as they win
games a B is gonna have to you know
really transform to that mindset and the
jury is still out on that
but I just don't understand how anyone
stops this often Phillip Dorsett was
running wide open and now he's the
fourth receiver and like the seventh
target on the team yeah wait till Rob
Gronkowski comes back for the stretch
run I'm just joking I actually don't
think he will although who I mean who
knows I just I look at this and I look
at secondaries across the NFL the great
ones have two guys that can cover at a
high level the great ones and usually a
third guy that's an above-average
starter the average teams have usually
one guy that can cover maybe two I just
don't understand and the Patriots
offensive line I think they're all the
injuries looks phenomenal it's just wild
that we've gotten to this point Matt I
think the only defense that can match up
with the Patriots offense is the
Patriots no disrespect for the Eagles
the Bears have to score with them and
control walk like the Chiefs are gonna
have to score with them and control the
clock as much as you can and hopefully
you get the ball last exactly yeah and
we just saw this on Monday Night
Football we did I'll say this man I
don't know anyone who can compete with
the Patriots on paper right now if they
stay healthy and we did see Marcus can
and get banged up in week one so that
will be interesting to watch but I don't
know anyone who can and there's a reason
this signing happened and Vegas shot the
Patriots to the top of the odds favored
to win another championship so it's not
even like oh if this works out and I saw
Bill Belichick was asked to x' day
morning by reporters how do how do you
think Antonio Brown will basically
acclimate to the system and he was like
you guys asked me the same thing about
Randy Moss how'd that work hey Bill is
so confident I'm sure he already I'm
sure they had a conversation Saturday
where he was like we want you here we
know you want to be here here's how
we're doing things if you don't like it
don't waste our time
so I there's no one in my and I say this
someone I picked the Chiefs to win the
Super Bowl and I did that before the a
be signing happened I would love to be
able to change my pick but I'm not gonna
do it they're just so good and like you
said Connery this is a Patriots team
that they were built to win a Super Bowl
without a B Josh Gordon looks freaking
amazing
he was unstoppable and I don't I don't
like to take away too much from week one
the steelers looked like trash no one
could stop Josh Gordon
no one get stuck yeah I said Phillip
Dorsett we didn't even really see
Edelman do that much because although he
needs to make in place yeah I think the
Steelers secondary much like a lot of
teams is in trouble I mean we saw the
Steelers the Browns and the Jets it just
looks like they really can't cover
anyone right now and I think there are
somewhat of expectations for at least
all three teams for at least two of
those teams when it comes down to it
it's fascinating I picked the Saints to
win the Super Bowl obviously I'm not
just gonna move off of that but it's
very hard to expect nothing less than a
Super Bowl for New England right now but
everything is about injuries and Josh
Gordon this gives them insurance Matt
because Josh Gordon has been mr. the
ultimate player you cannot rely on and
hopefully now you can but you'd be
foolish to think that now if you lose
him you sit there and you go okay we got
Edelman and a B will survive Dorsett who
played really well the other night will
survive another team that has made a lot
of key additions recently and just a
brutal brutal ending but what a game is
the Houston Texans and I think it's
worth having this conversation right now
because he almost gets lost in the
shuffle thanks to how well Pat mahomes
has played from that draft class we got
to start having a conversation about
deshaun Watson being a top 10
quarterback in this league I think he is
I also me too I'll summarize I talked up
deshaun Watson how this is my guy and
yes we all love Pat Michelle Watson
should have never been lost in the
conversation behind guys never Baker
Mayfield like how the [ __ ] are you gonna
say here today and say Baker who in four
straight possessions lost the game for
the Browns is a better quarterback than
two Sean Watson who he won the game for
them last night it's not his fault that
the defense absolutely cloud to the bed
it is not on him the guy won the game
and the defense lost it for them I think
DeSean is I I truly believe that in a
couple years we're gonna talk about Pat
mahomes deshaun Watson and hopefully
carson wentz if he can remain healthy as
the best quarterbacks in football yeah I
would think so too I would think so too
and you got to give even and I do think
the offense helps which that's fine
it helped same with Jared Goff it's
helped him before I think dak Prescott
in Dallas as long as Kellen Moore is
there he's gonna put it's gonna put up
phenomenal numbers so it's nice to see
this new
era of quarterbacks not look like good
players look like superstar level
players absolutely superstar level
players and it just makes the league
better when things are like that one
thing that surprised me and I didn't put
this on our rundown of all the
first-year head coaches Matt Lafleur
they one he had a really good debut Zach
Taylor the Bengals offense looked really
good Keller Moore's offense and Dallas
looked really good a lot of the young
offensive minds that we were waiting to
see how's this gonna look this year they
did really really well
the Bengals almost beat the Seahawks
Andy Dalton had a career day the most
yards he's ever thrown for I think was
like 418 yards so these young offensive
minds got off to a hot start and even
after a lifeless first half cliff and
Kyler really turned it on in the second
half and overtime in the quarter once
things got spread out you could just see
that change yeah completely change so
it's it's a lot of fun this new era now
it's week one there's a lot of teams
that something has just come out flat
we've seen we've been lied to from week
ones but I think it was an optimistic
start we can't forget about the NFL
Draft as we get caught up covering
college football and the NFL season one
thing Connor and I are gonna try to do
regularly on the Wednesday show is take
you through some of the things we're
seeing from our time on the road from
the games for scouting we're gonna call
it draft radar buddy I got to start with
our guy chase young you can defense for
Heisman this guy hashtag yes just let's
just talk about him about the he's the
best defensive player in college
football he might be the best player in
college football
chase young I know he's mellows number
one player he's my number two player
have you have you ranked him yet what
what have you seen from this he's just
he's a monster
it's not having seen a better defender
in the country right now and I thought
over summer Grant Delpit it could be
that top defender but in terms of just
playmaking ability and pro traits I have
not seen a better player than chase
young it's as Bennis it's been simple as
that yeah he already has three sacks on
the season eight tackles and he's doing
it with you would expect they played
Indiana or excuse me they play Indiana
in this coming week they haven't played
any one great that Cincinnati team they
just ran right over them chase Young is
doing it not which just was speed though
it's not like he's playing mid-majors
and just running around him he's doing
it with hand usage Melo and I were
breaking this game down he's
like stabbing guys with an inside arm
and then looping dropping his shoulder
he's beating guys with agility with hand
usage chase young looks unstoppable if
the team that has the number one pick
does not need a quarterback and doesn't
trade chase young should be the pick
like it's for me it's really that simple
and I've had a lot of people say like
what about Kayla Vaughn chase on what
about AJ up in essa I like yes guys I
love those guys but they are not chase
young sorry yeah I'm with you I think
you look at he keeps offensive lineman's
hands off of him so well and it allows
him to do so many different things
whether it's good after the quarterback
or read and react to run even seemed to
drop back and read screens so the level
that chase young is playing at so far
through just these short weeks here has
been amazing
I'm gonna go on the offensive side of
the ball and highlight somebody that is
not getting enough love Lynn Bowden from
Kentucky and this mat this player
reminds me of the scene of Friday Night
Lights where boobie miles uncle is
watching him practice and talking about
him play and he's like he could fill the
Gatorade cooler walk the dog paint your
back porch oh and he can pass Bowden
this week completed a 32 yard pass had a
60 plus yard kick return called back as
of a penalty had a long punt return had
two really good rush attempts and caught
like seven passes for 50 plus yards in a
touchdown Kentucky just put the ball in
this man's hands he is one of the best
special teams players in the country
he's the most reliable receiver on the
team and he's handling so many different
roles right now for this Kentucky team
and I loved him talking all that [ __ ] on
the field before the game they had a
great clip of him this player is
exciting and he's one of those players
that he might get lost in the shuffle
because he's playing at Kentucky he's
not catching passes from you know
Heisman guys like two or Herber but at
the end of the day he has NFL traits and
he's one of the more exciting play
making threats in the country yeah and
he might have to do even more because
their quarterback Terry Wilson nothing
injury and throwing the ball more yeah
Oh Lenny might be throwing the ball he
is exciting man a junior 6-1 200 pounds
I'm very excited to see him as we
into more of an SEC schedule but
Kentucky's to an O and he is a huge part
of that reason I said a J up in Essen
just a moment ago that everyone's asking
about him I want to highlight my man a
kid because even though he's not chase
young I still have a J upon us as a
top-five player in this class we saw to
get against Rutgers he got his first
sack in the season he's just so dynamic
he's so strong
excellent excellent size six six he's up
to 280 pounds it's it's really
impressive what he's able to do at that
size you know I get like a Cameron
Hayward type vibe from him sometimes but
then he flashes more athleticism than
that even so I think there's just a ton
of potential with epinasty this is his
first true year as a starter and as Iowa
another team that's really off to a
great start there to know they're
leading the Big Ten West
I think epinet is I mean obviously gonna
be an All Conference type guy he's gonna
make a case for an all-american type
season it just might be he and chase
young at the end of the day those might
be your all-american bookends yeah the
way he drives tackles backwards and that
leaping sack he had he's really a
do-it-all player still a young player
like we always said last year in more of
a I'm not a part-time role but
definitely not that lack of a starter he
had a phenomenal season
I'm the stat sheet on the field on the
film speaking of someone else this is
another player that might get lost in
the shuffle because of Jerry Judy but
the guy across from him Henry rugs
there's baby talk oh baby is right there
up in the talk that he's a sub for three
player I mean you're those rumors from
spring/summer you know you raise your
eyes a little bit and you go okay maybe
but that might be school times we talk
to schools how they do it whether they
run on the turf whether it's laser time
all of that I think rug speed is real
when you look at that little screen pass
that to ethroo to him and him shoot up
the field against New Mexico State
didn't even look like he was in you know
full throttle mode yeah and he was
blowing by everyone rugs has an a rare
athletic profile and I think we're gonna
see more of that on display as teams
Keyon Judy more I can remember hearing
about how rugs excuse me when he was in
high school because he broke the like
Alabama has seven
which we don't have in Missouri I think
actually 5a is our biggest but he broke
the 7a in Alabama the 100-meter dash he
ran a 10-5 8 in high school so if you're
not like a track guy if you're running
sub 11 like that's really really good 10
5 8 is freaking amazing I know that it
at what I guess they call it junior pro
day he ran a 4 to 5 electronic times now
that is coming from guys at Alabama they
could fudge that a little bit but I've
talked to Scouts who believe it like
they think that he's 4 to 5 they think
that he's John Ross fast basically so
it's easy to caught up watching to uh
and Nagi Harris and and Jerry Judy and
all the talent they have there Henry
rugs would be the number one receiver at
any school not Alabama yeah he's that
amazing last guy I want to highlight and
this hurts this is sting so much but I'm
also I'm so happy for the player but I'm
just so hurt by it
Joe burrow absolutely carved the
University of Texas he made guys like
cadence turns look invisible
he made Jalen Greene look like he should
be playing for North Texas or Texas
State and Jalen Greene's a player that
like I even have said this dude has all
the traits he is young he's a sophomore
he was making a second start Joe burrow
went right at him
Joe burrow should be in the Heisman
conversation we're gonna have to
completely revisit Joe burrow as a draft
prospect his last three games going back
to the UCF bowl game are perfect he is
thrown one interception this year to
nine touchdowns 749 yards in two games
won against the school that's wearing
DBU t-shirts it is amazing the heat Joe
burrow was the bright spot of that game
Saturday night you know my love for San
Mellinger you know my love for BJ foster
who unfortunately got hurt
Joe borough has McConaughey saying [ __ ]
in Ashe medium and a cowboy hat on the
sideline wheat this dude is a top five
Heisman candidate and I am so excited to
continue to evaluate him as a draft
prospect if you could do it he did
against Texas with that dumbest [ __ ]
three-man rush that I'm still upset
about but if you can do that you're on
the radar I
has to be I mean we're looking at a
player that coming into the season we
probably thought would be you know a day
three quarterback prospect that'll have
a Senior Bowl opportunity and looked
like a you know a backup kind of guy
wipe that off the table he's gotten so
much better this year the third and
Long's more ridiculous even when the
pocket got really muddy he kept this
eyes downfield and and the feel in the
pocket that's what looked so good he had
the feel of how much time he had and
always found somebody breaking free for
a long gain and he just has the attitude
that you always trust him in the big
spot already bagger there's a little bit
of swagger there and he was waving
goodbye to the crowd
Joe borough is fun I think this team
believes in him and I think this team
believes in this offense that's what's
really exciting too it's a totally
different look of LSU but a really fun
start for the Tigers the last one on our
list here Anthony McFarland jr. from a
Maryland offense that simply cannot be
slowed down right now I mean he didn't
even really need to play much in their
first game but this one against a very
good Syracuse team where they stomped
them 63 220 sorry man I hate to bring it
up again
real tight on that one it's fine three
touchdowns one receiving two rushing
over 70 yards rushing
I just think McFarland is one of those
under-the-radar backs because he's a
smaller guy he's about five nine he's
under 200 pounds very elusive very
shifty he can catch the ball he can
really has a great burst on the outside
run so when you look at this Maryland
offense with all this production if
you're looking for one of the key draft
guys it really starts with McFarland out
there yeah I put $100 on that game thing
in Syracuse would at least cover you
know they would assume they would cover
but Josh Jackson at quarterback he has
been great for them and said he's the
kind of guy Virginia Tech could really
use the quarterback right now it's it's
unfortunate that he's not there anymore
but Jackson and mcFarland are basically
unstoppable for that Maryland office
right now let's take a break when we
come back we'll rip through week one of
the NFL season giving you our takeaways
from the biggest storylines
all right Connor let's go through week
one man and there was a lot of action
some of it I had to go back and get
caught up on because we were flying home
from Austin Texas on Sunday morning my
goodness that's what day it was number
one thing is I need
monday night football doubleheader or if
you want to make it Sunday night
football doubleheader I'm okay with that
give me two games one of those nights
and let's just forget Thursday Night
Football I'm with you all the way the
product product of Thursday Night
Football how much the team's hate it I
understand for revenue purposes why they
do it but it's not even close I mean
it's it's not even close and obviously
on the East Coast it's a little tough to
stay up for those double headers that
kickoff that late but it's worth it the
games are great
there's just early in the week just like
all the games together in that you know
whatever it is 36 hour window a football
it's just way better and I think it
would be better for injury reports we
got Matt we had I mean just two great
games on Monday night after our Sunday
night's tinker two great games I enjoyed
this I will gladly say bye the fourth
quarter I was done oh I did not watch
the fourth quarter no there was no
reason after halftime that's why I asked
Melo did you watch it I watched first
half yeah that's all you needed to watch
yeah we did have two very good Monday
night games you know what actually
surprised me most and I almost tweeted
this and I was like oh no I'll save it
for the show if you did not break your
collarbone or clavicle this weekend your
regulations yes because most people did
Tyriq ill dislocated nick foles broke
his Devin Funchess broke his this I've
never seen so many collarbone injuries
in one week of an NFL season I think
there were more collarbone injuries than
there were knee injuries yeah is that it
felt that way you know what you here's
why I think it is everyone's hitting
high these days or like you don't want
to hit guys in the knee anymore you
can't hit guys in the head obviously I
know everyone's just hitting in the
chest they're dry it they're driving
players right in that area that has to
be it because if you go anywhere in the
torso
it's gonna be pretty much clean unless
you go fall Hopkins suplex which should
not be a penalty by the way it should
not be a penalty I agree it's ridiculous
it's a wrap tackle I don't care if it's
it's violent look at the sport you're
not hitting him in the crown of the
helmet you're not cutting him low
it's I mean usually when guys land from
a suplex like yeah it's gonna hurt I
just don't think it should be a penalty
but that's another conversation
definitely some big injuries we'll start
with Tyreke first do you think this
opens the door a little bit for me Cole
it does you know what surprised me that
was wint I Tyreke went out in the first
quarter of this game really Sammy
because Sammy Watkins show it we didn't
really see Travis Kelce get that
involved we didn't see Miko get involved
at all it was just and some of it might
have been because Pat rolled his ankle
as well so I feel like they were very
conservative they had a big lead they
were able to just she was running the
ball and control the clock but I think
he does open the door for me Cole
especially on more of those like gadget
type touches or I shouldn't even say
gadget the designed touches for Tyreke I
think we'll see some of those go to me
Cole now is you know as they try to
soften up this out the defenses I hit
play but Sammy Watkins being healthy and
playing like he did is a great sign for
the Chiefs
it's a terrible sign for the rest of the
AFC because a for him to go off like
that if they have Sammy Watkins catching
nine balls for almost 200 yards and
three touchdowns that's terrifying for
the rest of the league so I think with
Tyreke out yes they're gonna feel it and
he's won we don't know when he's gonna
return with Nick Foles he's on IR and
we've seen already our guy gardner
minshew with that beautiful mustache of
his come in and play very very well he
completed 13 straight passes to start
the game that's the most ever for a
quarterback in a debut game so gardner
minshew comes in it plays very well
against the bad chiefs defense let's be
honest and a game that was already won
for Kansas City but I was really
encouraged by Gardner they they did
trade for Josh Dobbs the 5th round picks
gonna go to Pittsburgh for that but I
like the Jacksonville is gonna roll with
Gardner and see what he can do he's a
guy like we loved the person in the
draft process you know he's just such a
great story like no one wanted him he
was gonna be a ga at Alabama than Mike
Leach cause he goes to Washington State
has an amazing year he had a really good
Senior Bowl week and now he gets picked
up by Jacksonville and he's starting in
the NFL week to after a really strong
week one so I look at the AFC we saw a
little bit of a reset because you know
foals is out Jackson it looked really
really bad ty reeks hurt what's that
gonna do to Kansas City the Patriots are
now adding Antonio Brown
and then in Indy like that was such a
good game between Indy and the Chargers
but now Nick Nick Devin Funchess excuse
me is out with a broken clavicle as well
so so many injuries have just had a
ripple effect through the AFC right now
and through all that the Titans
absolutely steamrolled the Browns which
no one saw coming on Cleveland's own
field so it's gonna be interesting for
guard Gardner Minshew here you know
dealing with Houston next week and then
that Tennessee team on Thursday night
it's not gonna be easy for him I think
specifically what Houston you have to
worry about you constantly have to keep
up with an electric offense that's
healthy I mean Watson his healthy will
Fuller's healthy Hopkins is probably the
best receiver in football you know when
you look and Duke Johnson looks really
good so that's gonna be a tough matchup
we're gonna learn a lot about Gardner
very very early here but it's exciting
it really is exciting it's good to see
him come in have some success and
obviously Funchess you know it was good
to see CY Hilton not really take a step
back that team could it came out to
moralize after the Andrew Luck
retirement and I really didn't get that
vibe at all from them yeah I didn't
either I really thought you know Jacobi
bracelet played well in that game you
mentioned this briefly the biggest
disappointment for me was the AFC North
I expected so much I expected at least
the Steelers to be competitive
I thought the Browns were gonna beat the
Titans and they got beat down let's
cover the 5-point line I said this
earlier in the show there was there was
a time in that game where it was
actually pretty close and then Baker
throws in the span of four possessions
he throws three interceptions and had a
turnover on downs some of that's gonna
go on the offensive line but some of its
on him like he just was making poor
decisions he was holding on the ball too
long in the pocket and not even like so
you could say I like to often struggle
the offensive line whatever this was a
team of so let's have a good defense and
they've got just beat to [ __ ] by Marcus
Mariota and the Tennessee Titans and
Derrick Henry who I will still die on
this hill is not as good as the player
we saw on sorry so it's crazy to me this
isn't the hitting the panic button on
the Browns yet but I think this show had
two concerns with Cleveland going into
the year and those were number one the
offensive line number two is Freddy
could kitchens a head coach in the NFL
when you have eight
penalty's that's discipline yeah it's
discipline now you're going into you
know Monday Night Football it's now a
must-win for the Jets and Browns the
Jets absolutely blow a 16 nothing lead
with a quarter and a half against the
bills at home just awful
the Browns don't look alive in the
second half against Tennessee
you have a Monday night football matchup
where the both of those teams are gonna
be going in with a must-win mindset
right now and both of those head coaches
are already sweating and will be there
it'll be a lot of fun we will be there
so come to LA 11 if you want to see the
show we'll be kicking off around 6
o'clock it's gonna be an awesome party
thanks a lot
11 those guys The Winter's Bros put on a
crazy tailgate the big jets bus I mean
you really can't miss it so if you're
gonna be at the game
get there early come hang out with us we
always have stuff we're giving away the
show's always fun it's we're just gonna
be one big party in the MetLife Stadium
parking lot and I have a surprise for
everyone who will be there
yes he does I can confirm he has a
surprise gonna be legendary so we talked
about this a I've seen north
disappointment which the Bengals were
better than I expected
that won't be I want to be loud and
clear about that as were the Ravens for
me the Ravens my Baltimore Ravens Miami
is should be ashamed of themselves this
year I was reading and I didn't get to
watch all of that game as it was
happening because it was the one o'clock
slate there's a million things going on
that that first drive where Baltimore
just ran it down their throat and Mark
Ingram looked like he was 20 years old
again
the Dolphins never got out of their
nickel defense right you can take all
you want with personnel that's on the
coach right there yeah I mean what are
they doing it is phenomenal and I I want
to give lamar jackson so much credit it
is hard for 17 of 20 and five TDs in
high school it's hard so to do it
against NFL talent regardless of the the
the philosophy and strategy of the
coaches in the front office that's hard
to do I want to give Lamar Jackson so
much credit and I hope I hope at the end
of the year we're sitting here at
I'm saying guys I was really wrong about
him he developed so much better as a
passer and I think we even saw some of
that on Sunday the Dolphins are
embarrass ed embarrassingly bad it is
just it's ugly
there's no fight I didn't see anyone
from the Dolphins so I was like oh man
because I this woman came somewhat back
and watched yesterday I didn't see
anyone where was like damn that do try
playing hard the offensive line there's
no effort the run game no effort like
there was nothing they're not tackling
defense time and tackling no like there
was no effort they just completely
rolled over and gave up I don't know I
don't know Brian Flores but I know so
many people were very excited about the
combination of Flores and Chris Greer
that they were gonna turn this team
around god I am are they just gonna burn
it to the foundation and rebuild it I
guess but you just simply can't do that
I understand tanking and I if the
Dolphins end up with two out of all of
this it's a step in the right direction
but that's the team he's walking into no
I don't think Tom Brady could save that
in his prime Hollywood Brown played
eight snaps Matt he had four catches for
150 yards and two touchdowns right eight
snaps amazing it's like a scrimmage it's
just and I was talking with somebody
about this and pro football talk Mike
Florio it came out with the report that
right around the same time I was having
this conversation with somebody that
worked in the league for a long time and
was saying you know that players are
calling their agents requesting trades
and at the same time I was having this
conversation it basically was that you
can't do this
this level of tanking you could tank in
the NFL like quietly I think we've seen
a couple teams do it in recent years
this level of tanking veterans will quit
they will fake injuries they will not
lay their body on the line on the field
and if you're Kenny Stills you've got to
be laughing as you catch that touchdown
last night talk about a change of
fortune but I think this level of
tanking is it's dangerous honestly is
very dangerous
I reminds me of Cleveland where he was
like oh yeah the ownership was on board
Shashi Browns gonna just trade away
everyone who's an ass
they're gonna cumulate draft picks
they're gonna draft well and they're
gonna you know have this very analytical
approach to team building and because
ownership got embarrassed players got
tired of losing and that's thing like
you can't go to Laramie tops when Kenny
Stills me like dudes listen we want to
uh so we're gonna lose every game we can
this year because we want to uh they're
gonna be like well no I have to bust my
ass every day and be prepared and
trained and just so you guys can lose
every game like you said you're gonna
lose your veteran so fast so it's kind
of like it's a black mark or a black eye
a little bit for the NFL that the
Dolphins are this bad but again it's
week one like you said we've all been
lied to by week one I don't want to over
react to anything but we it is smart to
at least acknowledge it one last note
I'm so happy for our guy Josh Jacobs who
had a brilliant game really on Monday
Night Football and a surprise win
everything that Oakland's been dealing
with they kind of get a win over the
Denver Broncos maybe that says a lot
about Denver maybe it says more about
Jon Gruden in the Oakland Raiders than
we expected but I was really really
encouraged by the night he had 23
carries two touchdowns had one catch for
28 yards as well and big josh Josh
Jacobs looks like the real deal for this
offense he does and it's exciting to see
Oakland has made all these investments
on the offensive line
I thought the offensive line played
great against pass rushers like Von
Miller Bradley Chubb Josh Amos was able
to get in the end zone and look you know
as advertised Derek Carr had time
Darren Waller had a solid game I think
when you look at you know is this who
Oakland is I don't know yet because I
think Denver is gonna struggle this year
I just think they'll won't really go a
lot of places with Joe Flacco but at the
end of the day this is step in the right
direction for John Bruins Raiders after
all of the [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
you go through with Antonio Brown where
you almost forgot this team has to play
football games to come out and get a win
on your home field like that and the
young guys are excited Cleveland Farrell
Jonathan Abram obviously Jacobs it's a
quiet guy but he's a huge part of that
win if you're an Oakland fan it's
probably been a miserable miserable
couple of weeks here it's good that you
have something to smile about they
absolutely have some young guys to
smother I think we'll see those those
three first-round draft picks really
emerge and the
Trevon Mullen in there as well very
happy to see a friend of the show Gary
Connolly he text me this morning he's
okay after getting carted off with that
neck injury so that was that's one of
those do you like holding a breath
you're like oh god please no so really
really good to see him happy let's take
a break buddy when we come back get
through some draft on draft questions
it is draft on draft time to close out
the show and I want to say thank you
again to our friends from pluckers in
Austin who hooked us up we had such a
great time there it was an amazing setup
on the patio watch a college football
and we had some fun with LSU fans as you
probably saw on my Instagram we had fun
with all the Texas fans there it was a
great time I'm excited though for Monday
night in East Rutherford lot 11 plans
are being finalized right now for the
Madison Wisconsin tailgate on September
21st I know a lot of you guys have asked
some things have kind of changed good
things have changed leading up to the
game so we've had to be a little
flexible about where we'll be but I hope
to have that information wrapped up
today and we'll be tweeting it out and
talking about it on the Friday morning
show all right first question Connor
from Charlie maliska who signs Lincoln
Riley first Dallas or Houston I think
alex has a coach yeah I would first so
long would have send the Cowboys but
Kellen Moore might save Jason Garrett's
life that's what I think's Lee I really
think there's a chance I know it's one
game but I think I mean all there's been
hype about Kellen Moore for a year and
when you go out and start like that I
don't know I think it's Jason Garrett
has been Teflon and if this this team
looks better than any team he's had so
the thing with Houston is I don't think
Lincoln Riley will go there I really
don't I mean it depends who they hire at
GM but it's gonna be hard to get Lincoln
at Oklahoma here is like so that's what
I've heard that a lot is that you know
yeah he's competitive but he loves
college football and he is good at it
he's gonna have three straight iseman
Trophy winners at quarterback why would
you leave that and I think Lincoln is
smart enough to not just go to the NFL
to go to the NFL like yeah he's young
enough to be patient I don't I don't
know if you know if the Freddy kitchens
experiment doesn't work I think that
Cleveland will
probably intrigued him because Baker's
there but I don't think that he's the
kind of guy that's gonna be like I want
to go coach the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
because I want a job in the NFL I think
if you're serious golf outing I make he
makes like six million dollars a year in
Lincoln he's fine
or in Norman excuse me he's fine I think
Cleveland is the sneaky one if Freddie
doesn't work and 18 penalties in week
one is evidence that it might not work
that would be electric what Majan drives
a girdle I mean Baker hires hired the
first head coach he hired Hettie Hettie
Hettie Hettie Hettie coach kitchens man
when you look at it
what if Belichick retires and Lincoln
goes the New England well josh mcdaniels
gets that job the second bill retires
that's a mistake yeah you see drive mail
that was awesome play that was awesome
it was like they just took him out of
the pads and put a headset on him right
away or bellary's yeah rough haircut
yeah yeah all right
it's miles with a lot of s's where do
you have jaylen Hertz ranked right now
and where do you see him getting drafted
and if you ask the successful season
under Lincoln this year also what do you
need to see from him to get his ceiling
as a quarterback to get drafted I uh
I mean I watched week one because we
were on the road I did not watch their
week to game hell I even if they played
week - honestly I'm in such a fog trying
to get caught up on NFL right now
I like Jalen hurts a lot we've talked
about this a little bit here's what I'll
say I don't want a hedge on this I just
want to be upfront notch with everyone I
think right now he is still a limited
quarterback in any ways that is being
aided a lot by his system that's not say
he's only a system quarterback I still
see a lot of roughness in his throwing
motion there's a lot of a delay there
they played South Dakota so they did I
guess yeah the Coyotes right I think I
would safely say right now he is a day
three prospect now here's where I will
give you a little bit of perspective two
years ago oh yeah this time of year
everyone and their brother said Baker
Mayfield was a day three prospect Connor
I remember being with you in December
with some Scouts and they thought
was a day three prospect in December and
we were excited about him sneaking into
round two back yes yes we were cuz I we
people go back and listen we loved Baker
and people like no no no no day three
day three oh you know I was like that
year I was like Jets getting a pass
rusher with a top ten pick and bent your
Mayfield around to Russell Wilson route
were golden yeah no he went number walls
and a year ago everyone thought Kyler
Murray was gonna go play baseball he
wasn't we weren't even scouting his
college games because we've been told by
people in Oklahoma and people in the NFL
they don't waste your time he's gonna
play baseball so a lot can change they
play UCLA this weekend they're gonna
kill them the one problem with Oklahoma
schedule is they don't play a good
defense until the college football
playoffs basically because you saw what
Texas did against LSU won good so I mean
Jalen looks amazing
you'd have to keep it in context you
know they've played South Dakota and
Houston two teams not really known for
the defense but I want to see him make
quicker decisions I think that's one
thing where I've seen him play a little
slow in the pocket and and then
mechanically I think he just needs to
clean some things up he's made a big
jump he always already just looks more
natural as a thrower but he doesn't have
the arm that Baker or Kyler had he might
be a better athlete the Baker I don't
know that he's a better athlete than the
Kyler he's just bigger yeah it's gonna
be interesting with him if if we you
know get credentials for Red River which
it depends on how long our event goes
that's how it always is for us it'll be
it'll make it a lot easier to see him in
person see him play against a good team
if not I think he'll be for us at least
we'll be a little skeptical until we see
him down at the Senior Bowl but the
steps are great I mean you asked me this
question this time last year and I would
have said he's gonna have to move
positions if he wants to play at the
next level I don't think that any
malhomme see that they running back yeah
they wanted him to say they wanted him
to play running back I mean he's got a
great mindset where he probably could
play any position you really asked him
to but I think he wants to be a
quarterback and I think he went to the
right place to get better at quarterback
which he's done so this is really just
the beginning for jaylen hurts and when
you see players like even obviously
Taysom Hill as always
go to example I'm kind of tired to that
one but tres McSorely had a nice summer
in that Baltimore offense you know
jaylen is easily gonna get an
opportunity when you see someone like
McSorely getting those opportunities so
right
a really good start for him and let's
see where it goes he's gotta get the
ball out faster I'm like sitting here
watching some clips like he's just it's
third and 22 again South Dakota and I
counted to seven like yeah well against
South Dakota you don't have to - it does
that - it's like all around him yep
underscore Jacob Bentley eight last
question if bris it doesn't work out at
quarterback who's the best fit for the
Colts offense or do you sign a vet and
try to go after Trevor I mean I think
that that offense Frank Reich is a good
enough coach that anyone would be a fit
but I think - it would fit I think
Justin Herbert would fit Jake from
definitely very naturally fits
Trevor hasn't been great guys like two
games in old T Rev is not looking like
the world beater that we maybe hoped
that he would become I've been talking
about Justin fields that year - right
though I know yeah it's I mean these are
young guys those two could be all world
when all said and done I'm excited about
both of them I think if if you think it
would take a lot for Brissette to be
moved on from after this year I think
that's what would be percent this year
percent next year and then 2021 that's
the most logical plan for me with the
Colts yeah I think it is as well I mean
you sign the guy to an extension you've
given him extra time to try to see what
he can be they believe in him they love
his leadership they really like his
skillset and I said is about the cold a
Marlin Mac had a great day on Sunday
which if you listen to this show you you
knew how much we loved him and thought
that he was gonna be a breakout guy this
year they don't have great skill
position players like T white hilton's
okay they're number two receiver Devin
Funchess was not great and has now hurt
their tight ends are just kind of like
afterthought guys who I know Eric you
weren't how to good here last year but
there's not a lot to write home about so
I think with Brissette if we could see
more of a focus on let's actually load
up assets around him because they need
more guys any playmakers to help him out
so I think that's where we see them go
if anything
yeah only Parris Campbell will really
need to you know start develop yes I
think
really quiet summer in a quiet star for
him and that doesn't surprise me but
that's a guy that you'll have to keep an
eye on because he can really make or
break the vertical game of that offense
yeah and hopefully Deon Cain eventually
become something yeah I know they really
liked him as a prospect coming out of
Clemson so yeah they've got some guys to
watch as far as development goes all
right man that is our show we will be
back Friday morning getting you
previewed and ready for college football
and NFL weekend and a reminder Monday
night Conor and I will be at Monday
night rounds good Jets the Battle of the
Owen one's I don't think anyone's
violent crowd really I'm really
surprised by that when we put that game
on a schedule I was like oh man like I
can see both teams want to know at this
point uh same funny how things work when
you don't have a kicker for months or an
offensive line or I might be kicking for
the Jets Monday night that might be our
surprise I'll kick man I gotta be get
Carli Lloyd out there somebody
somebody's got to be better than what
they've nobody if woody was here that
would have happened won-ho with that
zone yeah without a doubt
well I don't know is the Women's
National Team they're kind of at odds
with Woody's boss so maybe not fair so
very fair
I don't know what's David Beckham doing
we'll find somebody you know everybody
somebody who can kick for the jet levy
on kick he's got to be better than
whatever they have or just go for two
Mike that worked yeah some sense alright
that is our show for real we'll be back
Friday morning with mellow sitting
beside me don't forget you can watch the
show on YouTube Bleacher Report's
youtube channel we will yell at y'all
again Friday morning